[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non non non non non non non non
non non non non non non
[Musique]
au ralenti je soulève les
au bout de la vie
reste allongé je vais te rallumer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je te mords et encore et encore
ton dans le dos je souffle le mot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est mal à la folie
au ralenti je soulève les interdits
[Musique]
comme un grand bras de la
s'allonger je vais te rallumer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends attends attends attends
tu veux pas qu'on leur fasse avec
Mahmoud ouais
ta gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on a fait des choses à Miami quand tu
avais le covid
pour être une consultante
[Applaudissements]